can you please list the ways in which
the number five relates to all
manifestations of life
[Music]
okay so the first three episodes of
raised by wolves are now out on hbo max
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything i just want
to get into it as there's a lot to talk
about
but obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check them out yet then i
highly recommend that you check out now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for breakdowns on it every week and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
video
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
i'm your host definition now let's get
into race by wolves
okay so firstly before talking about the
episodes themselves
we have to talk about the title of the
show and how it plays into them
the phrase raised by wolves is an idiom
that often refers to someone who's
socially inept
or acting in a way that doesn't seem
normal however
it also refers to the story of romulus
and remus
two brothers that were according to the
legend raised by wolves
the pair later founded rome and the
roman empire
and according to the myth romulus killed
his brother this could hint towards the
direction that the show is going
but it also provides the subtext to
what's happening in it
predominantly the series is gonna center
around two androids named mother and
father
who fled the earth with human embryos on
the planet kepler-22b
the pair are attempting to raise the
last surviving one of these named
champion
amongst some earth-born children this is
how the show itself ties into the title
as it makes us question whether it's
possible for a synthetic person to raise
a human to be human
sure we could potentially program
something to carry this out
however we know that it's far more
complex than just black and white
and there are many facets to our species
both positive and negative
we see the conflict this causes and it
also makes us study the fault in
ourselves which caused the earth to
become inhospitable
now on top of the romulus and remus
metaphors there is of course the adam
and eve one
which too is deeply rooted in mother and
father they're pretty much arriving on a
planet after being cast out of what used
to be a paradise
they have to make their way through a
cold and unforgiving world
both were created in the image of man
similar to how adam and eve were created
in the image of god
and i love watching them arrive on the
planet and walk past a rotten tree
which of course was meant to be a
metaphor for the tree of knowledge
i say of course that's that's just how i
interpreted
now kepler is a barren wasteland looking
like one of the bad planets in
interstellar
but its name too holds a lot of meaning
in science the name kepler comes from
the german astronomer and mathematician
who's considered by many as the founder
of celestial mechanics
kepler was the first person to
accurately describe the elliptical
orbits of the earth and planets around
the sun
and he demonstrated that the ones that
are closest also move the fastest
kepler-22b is actually a real planet and
it's one that nasa have actually studied
because
it's very similar to our own earth it's
located about 587 light years from earth
and it has 290 days in its orbital
period
seems like a lovely place to go and i'll
definitely be rating it on tripadvisor
now a campion is a flower and the
character should be seen as someone
that's attempting to blossom
amongst the wasteland and all the issues
that come with being on the planet
campion is also named after the
android's creator and this could tease
that it was the character that tried to
send this arc out into space to flee the
dying planet
and who knows we may get more of his
backstory as the season goes on
the show opens with the voice of a child
stating that they were the first
that they were seen as pioneers pioneers
are often described as discovering
things
and this is both negative and positive
connotations depending on its usage
we see a nuke explode before mother and
father journey in their ship to kept the
22b
and after a bumpy landing they make the
planet their home
our first time jump is nine months and
this of course
plays on the birth cycle of a woman
birth cycle of a woman i can't believe i
i worded a sentence like that i'm
starting to talk like they are now
anyway the character mother really
becomes attached to the children
as they pretty much come from the
organic fluid within her body
that's used to grow them in many ways
she carried them
and they are her children i thought this
was an absolutely brilliant motif to
bring across
and it's almost cyclical how man created
machine and the machine created man
mother is clearly torn up when one of
the children early on seems to die
however they come to life and this
quote-unquote run of the litter
ends up as the last surviving member of
the group after the others fall either
to disease or accidental death
now early on mother tries to enforce the
idea of atheism into the children
and it seems to be putting across the
notion that it's as damaging as
enforcing strict religion is
growing up i was brought up to be quite
religious and then i became an atheist
for a bit before
settling on being agnostic i know that's
not really making my mind up
but i think because science can't
provide all the answers
we have to keep an open mind about
things and there are certain elements of
life that
just can't be explained purely by
numbers there's a famous saying that
facts don't care about your feelings
but juxtaposing this it's clear that
campion's feelings
don't care about the facts and that he
wishes to be spiritual
even though mother forbids this feelings
don't care about your facts
i'm getting that on a t-shirt anyway i
think that this show is saying that you
have to have an open mind to discover
things on your own
instead of having ideas forced upon you
either way as
that is very wrong this can lead to
brainwashing and it's better to have a
society that's open to discourse
rather than one that shuts down all
opinions in favor of one
the synthetics lie about the dangers of
the planet in order to try and keep the
children safe
and similar to humanity which they
criticize they use fear as a way to
control the population
mother's powers even come from her voice
and ridley scott is very much lacing
this with symbolism for how she lords
over her people
mother definitely doesn't come across as
that good of a person when she's saying
that all religion is bad
and that you have to say how 5 relates
to all manifestations of life
this way of thinking in binary terms
even begins to break mother herself
and we can clearly see that she's
wracked by the deaths of her children
even though it should be seen as
something scientific instead of
something that she feels
now there is a milk-like substance that
drips from her nose
and this did give me hope that the show
could be linked in some ways to my
favorite ridley scott franchise
alien now fox own that and they are
owned by disney
whereas warner brothers are the ones
behind the series i think that this was
left in as an easter egg so that fans
can draw their own conclusions
and both the androids in the show do
seem quite similar to the way that the
synthetics and david work in that
franchise
we will of course never get it confirmed
but i appreciate that scott carried
across this aesthetic
now father realizes that there's no way
to increase the human population
if campion is the only one left and thus
he attempts to signal a group
known as the mithraic angered by this
mother destroys him in a milk-filled
rage
and thus it's just her and champion left
on the planet
campion himself goes to the ship and
also sends out a broadcast which calls
them to the planet
and mother pretends to be human due to
ai being viewed as objects
rather than things that should have any
input juxtaposing this
the atheists clearly trust machine
learning as they allowed mother and
father to look after their children
whereas the mithraic use androids to do
their dirty work
the mithraic are heavily religious and
though it is hinted that they were the
cause of the war
this opinion is likely skewed for mother
as she was of course created by the
atheists
we see at the start of episode 2 that
mother and the synthetic family that she
belonged to
were some of the most devastating
weapons in the war these necromancers
were purely built to wipe out human life
and the name derives from a word that
describes someone who can communicate
with the dead
if the atheists were using these weapons
then it's clear that they weren't as
righteous
as we're led to believe they also
drafted kids into their war
and who knows they may have brought on
the conflict we learned very little
about the methodic
but i have a theory that due to the way
that the year turned with all
the planets to stabilization and death
that likely came with it
that they turned to religion this is of
course ended by champion himself
who does start to turn to religion after
the death of his siblings
in the morning they attempt to take
campion to their ship which mother
protests
and after a robot fight this descends
into her wiping them all out except for
marcus
the first episode had been quite slow in
my opinion up until this point
but when she goes full dr manhattan i
think it's absolutely brilliant
her design is very similar to the 1927
film metropolis
which was groundbreaking in cinema just
as in that was the first real machine we
ever saw on screen
the same idea is brought across to
mother with her being
a machine for this new world in that
film someone from a futuristic utopia
travels to the slums which are a
poverty-stricken wasteland
i feel like that's been reversed here
with mother traveling from a society
that's not that well developed
to one that is she journeys to the
methodic ship
impersonating marcus and then kills
almost all on board with his sonic
blasts
there's some irony to this as we find
that the markers we see
is actually someone impersonating the
real one and there's a lot going on here
in terms of what the truth is
she crashes the ship and then takes five
of the children
starting a new family on earth you also
see that mother has to remove her eyes
at this point
and the strobe-like light could be the
key to stopping her down the line
it's a lot of things to do with eyes
throughout the first three entries
and it does seem almost like a weakness
on both sides
i think that the mithraic believe that
if they die with their eyes open
they can't rest or may not go to the
afterlife but obviously let me know your
thoughts below
we discover that they are what allowed
mother to weaponize and that she removes
them in order to get the children to
trust her
they should be called weapon eyes hey
you having that
been a bit of a crap video this one
hasn't it now it seems like she wants to
do the right thing
but that of course goes up in the air as
we get further into the three episodes
in the second entry we see the war first
hand and also
marcus's transformation with his
girlfriend mary
we discover that he's really called
caleb and both these names of course
tie into the bible further hammering
home the religious aspects of the show
they kill their true counterparts and we
see that marcus is willing to do
anything that he can to survive
even taking their child as they board an
ark headed to the kepler
they even left the dogs behind and you
better hope that john wick isn't on this
because i'm not having that now this was
a 10-year journey for them
and whilst in stasis their minds
continued inside a simulation
so that they could grow and develop so
the kids that we see
are actually older mentally than their
bodies which does mean that they're far
more developed
than campion is back on kepler mother
reactivates father
who isn't too happy about getting shut
down she gifts him her eyes in order to
gain his trust
and this is mirrored by the mithraic
children who give campion a mouse
in order to try and get him on their
side the leader of them
hunter tells him that mother likely
poisoned campion's siblings
and i was actually in the middle of
writing that i thought this would come
up down the line
when it started to once more it's
revealed that the deaths were actually
caused by radiation
inside cabo's which mother and father
didn't detect
this caused the gen ones to die and they
did develop
some resistance that the new children
simply don't have
to make matters worse we then that
they've gone through a lot
and that one of the children tempest
actually views
mother as a savior because she saved her
from being abused further by a crew
member
that impregnated her i'm kind of dancing
around this a bit
just because of monetization on youtube
but it really is
a dark point in the show that's a
difficult watch
and it reminds us of a lot of similar
things in the church that were covered
up by the group
to not bring scandal to it she's
attacked by a group of animals
and this sets farther out on a quest to
attempt to secure one of them for study
across world marcus is saved by some of
the mythologic forces that survived the
crash
and we journey into the third entry with
mother telling the story of the three
little pigs
it's a tale that we tell children but in
it is the idea that one must make their
house strong and protected
in order to remain secure mother is
clearly showing that when the wolf's at
the door
one must be ready and i do think that
it's hinting out why she's kept her eyes
just in case the myth rake returned this
paranoia is warranted too
as we see across the planet marcus
pleads with the mithraic to storm the
camp in order to rescue the children
i love how they became attached to their
surrogate child much in the same way
that mother did hers
and it's clear that both sides just wish
to allow the human race to continue
no matter the cost of their own life
both believe that children are our
future
and if you teach them well you can let
them lead the way
now i actually have a theory that the
disease which the kids fall victim to
will also fall upon the adults and it is
possible that it will reappear later in
the season
perhaps even weaponized similar to how
smallpox was used on native americans
there's also mention of the pentagonal
prophecy which tells of an orphan boy
named in an empty land who will lead the
humans to a place
in which they can build a city of peace
though this does initially seem like
it's going to be champion
i think it could actually be their child
paul who is of course an
orphan himself marcus's identity is also
clearly going to get on earth
and the more and more people ask him
personal questions the more we start to
realize
it's not going to be long before someone
asks him something that he can't bluff
his way through
as they begin to go through the area
mother descends upon it
destroying one of the group's androids
and taking their eyes
now it is possible that the aliens come
from the hull which the ship fell into
and the explosion of it caused them to
awaken once more
campion is sure that mother is tricking
them and this makes him
flee with the rest of the children
mother takes antibiotics from the craft
and father brings these to the children
at the camp he proves mother didn't
poison them
and this showcases how paranoia can
often get in the way of the truth
champion is almost killed by a monster
on the planet but he's saved by
father who seems pretty gutted that he
betrayed him
mother goes looking for paul who
departed the camp and he becomes lost in
the wilderness
where he seemingly finds another child
now i do believe that this is tally
for the fact that he finds a doll before
stumbling across the hole
tally's body was never found in the
opening episode and
she did make her dolls similar to the
ones that we see
it is possible that these holes lead to
tunnels which pop up around the planet
and that tally emerged out of the one
that paul fell into
as she was away from the camp with no
real idea what direction it was
she likely remained in this area and who
knows the monsters may even be linked to
her
she also would not suffer from the
radiation poisoning that the other
children did
tudor not being exposed to it and with
the laugh that the mysterious figure
gives off
sounding very similar it does seem like
the two are indeed one
the same now as for the show itself i
don't know if it's because i watched the
first three episodes back to back
but i did find it a bit slow i'm still
really engaged in it though
and there is a lot here that i want to
see i'd obviously
love to hear your thoughts on it and
your theories so make sure you comment
below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of lovecraft country
which is going to be linked at the end
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection to one
random subscriber
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel
and drop a comment below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of september
so make sure you get involved you want
to support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on a
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you being the best i'll be definition
i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you